we talk about social media and the
impact that it has on your lives does it
ever make you feel more isolated yeah I
wouldn't say isolated but I think you
can definitely easily start comparing
yourself to other people and I think
that it can make you feel less than I've
started using certain platforms less
because I think people push out content
to make their lives seem different than
what they actually are and so when I
compare myself to other people it's not
actual reality that I'm comparing myself
to so that makes it really difficult you
refer to it as social media but I grew
up when it was social networking and I
focused on the networking portion of
social networking so as time moved on it
became social period instead of social
networking and I used I use Facebook and
Twitter and all that in order to meet
people in order to get my work out there
in order to get how conversations and
people I've gotten responses from people
I never would see in real life it gives
you access to individuals that you
otherwise would not have access to
that's the opposite of the isolation
piece where you can make new connections
oh yes I've made thousands of friends
social media majority of my friends that
I that I'm really close right now I've
met over social media so you've made
friends through social media both yeah
have you made friends through social
media I've made connect professional
connections via LinkedIn or similar
properties but not friends that I would
hang out with we're both more connected
now and less connected now right because
of Technology